what were you going to say about 24
because i want to know what it was like
because keefer was on the podcast i want
to know kind of like your keith and i go
great kevin knows i'm sober and never
has ever spent a minute i mean i keep
hearing all these things that people say
about him
and i've never encountered that
what he has and i i can't really speak
for him
but i can say what happened around is he
doesn't like it when people behave
unprofessionally and there's plenty of
actors that are like that it's like
please be quiet
we're trying to work here tristan bale
yeah i mean i understand that you just
don't want to do it when your mic's on
right or go as extreme perhaps well he's
so far down in the hole in what he's
doing i mean it's i've been we've all
been there i've been like this i've been
it's more of a it's you're upset but you
know like so it's like
al for the [ __ ] of [ __ ]
what are you doing you know banging
nails into it but good lord son and then
you laugh it off and you go on but he
just went mental you know wait it it's
just
we always get the tip of the iceberg
you know not to be crude but you [ __ ]
one goat
you know no now you're the goat [ __ ]
well it doesn't matter what else you've
done in your life but you've well you
kill one person you're a murderer
exactly well that's
kind of different you know
i suppose if the goat died
yeah yeah well
but the truth of it is is is the
intensity the intensity in performance
the intensity and we never have enough
time in television
and then the belief
you know you come in as a guest are you
in a very very different position than
you are somebody who has to work 16
hours a day
five days a week for x amount of years
sure you're getting the money but you
have to go to your trailer and do all
your business all your home stuff and no
life you've got no other right right you
know and so
i think
producers were very clever with with
jared and jensen and misha at least
giving them the option
of some spots here and there so my
character was written up i think to just
give some relief yes yes from that could
you do it right now could you do if
somebody offered you a lead role in a tv
series a one-hour drama i'd do it a
minute you could do it yeah physically
and mentally you think you could handle
those hours those being the lead i'm
never happier